out in public when you're at a bar or
anything like someone randomly be like
yo i want to hire you
to like strip at my like bachelorette
party or something like that and it's
just
like i'm not even a stripper
[Music]
the word [ __ ] is offensive
three two one go
why i somewhat agree is because
the term [ __ ] was actually coined
back in the 1800s when little people
could not you know live normal lives
they couldn't go to work a certain way
they couldn't go to school a certain way
and
that created an actual circus
lineage of little people who make their
livelihood
based on the word [ __ ] i understand
that it is very painful and it was
very painful for me as a child to hear
that word
but i think all of these people have
stopped and told someone
like you cannot refer to me by that and
i respect that as well but if someone is
like i just don't care and that's how i
make my money then do you
it's the ignorant people that use it
it's the fact that people that who
aren't ignorant that know the history
behind the word or know that the words
offensive
still use the word as the hook like
[ __ ] wrestling like you don't like
we don't see it called dwarf wrestling
or little person wrestling we call
like that word is the hook that brings
people in to me that
just says a lot of like oh we know it's
a bad word we know it offends you
we just don't give a crap i've worked in
the entertainment industry
for over a decade and i've also played
drums
on tour in a rock and roll band and i've
been reviewed as
the [ __ ] drummer it's really tough to
be taken seriously and also take your
project
seriously when you are referring to us
in an offensive way ask me what my name
is
and call me by my name people fetishize
me
three two one go
for those of you that agree i am very
curious what
you guys come across because i am like
lost here i'm like wait people fetishize
about you
congratulations man before meeting my
wife i
i dated advertise women but it was also
like out in public when you're at a bar
or anything like someone randomly come
up to
me and friends and be like yo i want to
hire you to like
strip at my like bachelorette party or
something like that and it was just
like i'm not even stripper i'm just
chilling at the bar with my friends
i feel like as a female little person we
definitely get fetishized a lot
i almost think as a little person too
people don't think we are like real and
have like real feelings like we're some
type of
like mythical creature or whatever and
i'm like no i'm a real person i'm a lady
and the fact that you're talking to me
like that
is it's bad i've also done a lot of
entertainment gigs
like ali has and it is an open
door to invite all of these skeezy
people and invitations into your
face you know it's they're they're right
there especially when you're
in a uh like you said when you're in a
bar or a club
and people are drinking then this gets
amplified and it's it's even
more like over the top a lot of average
sized people
also look at it like oh i've never been
with someone like that before it's
almost like a bucket list
you know what it looks like with a
little person and how
crazy can we get yeah can you tell me
where you go
to meet these bucket lists i'll tell you
man i'll tell you
i'll give you some numbers um i feel
like because i'm a guy
and a little person i don't get
fetishized like how she said which makes
me feel very sad but also like i don't
all like in a weird way i kind of want
to experience that but also don't
with the stuff that you said watch it's
going to happen though yeah yeah that's
right
happened though wait but i have a
question do you have social media
yeah really and you don't like no one
no one has ever slid into my dm to be
like hey
i want to tower over you really i mean
some of my friends they normally tell me
you're so lucky
because you know everyone wants to go
like with you
and stuff like that it might be fun one
night
on one day when you are like kinda in
the mood for
it or whatever but um in my case it's
been
a nightmare since i started like around
like my
last years of high school i've been an
online
sleuth and an online nerd since i was a
kid
15 years of my life is compiled on the
internet and i've spent
half of that time warding off what i
call
lp collectors oh and and also if you
want to sound cool and you know a little
person you can use the term lp
i would say i would have
people messaging me dming me while i was
a teenager
up to this day you know can i have sex
with you because you are a little person
that kind of messes you up as a teenager
you have to wonder like how far is
somebody going to take it
exactly we're we're little people and
then also we're women
so then it's like there's a whole safety
thing that you have to worry about too
like oh yeah are they going to just pick
you up and take you off well
i have straight up choked people out
like in defense of someone trying to
pick me up
so hard and not giving up that i'm
actually jamming like
my full core and body into their throat
just to like get them off of me i hate
it but it almost makes me
like not used to human touch as much
because i'm so used to like
do not pick me up do not [ __ ] pick me
up
i want to have children three
two one go
oh wow we're all over the place oh
children
you know i love kids i think they're
amazing wonderful cute
um i think that that ship has sailed
and sank or whatever so i don't i don't
think that's a possibility
for me but more power to anyone else
that does it
as a average size person or a little
person my parents are average height
it was always one of those things where
they made me feel like i was just like
everyone else with me and my wife it's
one of those things where i want to
bring up a kid and make him feel that
same exact way but
explain to him that there's going to be
things that are going to be tough
a little mini me teach you to play
guitar
a lot of things you said like growing up
you and i probably relate this in the
same way that
our parents never really knew how to
explain our situation
to us the ability to kind of relate to
my kid in that way
is something that i am kind of looking
forward to i
i don't think i've had like a bad life
or anything like that but
if i'm gonna focus on all the problems
or the main problems that i've ever had
is probably related to my height
so i just do not wish that like
on my kid you know what i'm saying the
whole like going to a school like all
like
trying to probably like get a day the
whole like i want to be just like my
friend so i want to like play this type
of sport
and i'm not allowed to but like i said
this is how i see it right now and how
i've seen it in the last five years
maybe in the future
i don't know i get like a partner and
and my mind changed i don't know i don't
know
this is how i say it right now i'm gonna
tell you this i think
with everything that you've gone through
what not you paved
such a great road yourself and your if
you decide to have a child
i think you would be a great dad you
know because you went through all that
stuff and like you
spaced it your concerns are completely
legitimate because like there's also
like the other
medical fears for people like us as well
yeah but that's my thing like right now
like i'm okay with myself
like right now i actually see it as an
advantage it's i just don't wish what i
went through like to anyone
i don't think anybody's trying to change
your mind because man be into your young
20s and enjoy it you know what i mean
but also there's there's an element
where you never know what you're going
to get no matter what
you know and unless you adopt and that's
where you know
i think even that i mean the genius
right there my grandchildren
still have like the thing about to bring
it i was just trying to cut my
line right here
i appreciate when people offer to help
three two one
go
the only two women came over to strongly
agree so i can attest that definitely
i appreciate the help to do a lot of
things on a daily basis being this small
is
really challenging prime example going
to the grocery store
all the stuff that i want is always on
the top shelf of course
so you know half the time if there's not
somebody around i have to
actually do the climbing like it's like
right rock climbing all the way to the
top to get what i want
but i love it when there's somebody on
the aisle i don't hesitate i ask for
help
i had average height family members when
i was a kid
back then we didn't really have an
understanding of people disabilities
and so it would be very much that thing
of like prove to me
you can do it if i wasn't here and that
used to upset me
so badly i would be in a perilous
position where i might break my back
before i would ask for help so if i'm in
a position to be
like ask for help i always think that it
ends up opening more conversations to
people
to show that you are confident to not be
afraid to ask for what you need
i try and get like things myself you
know he's a climber
i'll use the car yeah yeah i'll just
like take the soda box
pile them up grab another card you know
just be like all right whatever
but like it's one of those things where
i try and do it myself
first but if i can't i i don't have an
issue being like
yeah and just being like i'm gonna need
you to get that they're like oh my gosh
can i get that for you and they like
freak out and they like i feel like they
just did the best duty of the day
yeah i'm with you on that because like
i'm not trying to like be rude to those
people that offer their help
it's just like i know you're trying to
be helpful but i need to know how to do
this wait i have a question for you guys
so you guys climb yes i climb too but
this is my only problem with that
when i see someone really hot or someone
that like
i don't know like i fight really hot i
just i can't you use the moment
i can't i can do the climbing thing when
there is someone really hot next to me
so what i do is like
i just don't get the the thing i just
don't get it why don't you just ask them
that way you're good
you start a conversation with them why
don't you ask them yeah
i was gonna say it okay it's a great end
man
i just i i just give up i'm like oh my
gosh i could get that next person you
know what i'm saying i normally climb
yin and yang you know i actually went
out of my way and bought like a
toy claw like one was like grab like
grabby toy claws
like to go to a grocery store it's like
oh i need to grab a bag of chips it's
like okay i cannot climb this i'm just
gonna use this claw
boom i like being little
three two one
go
it it took me a long time to get as far
as um
you know do i ever wish i was not a
little person no i'm very confident in
my skin and who i
am i don't know i think that just came
from like age and just
acceptance and i finally got to a point
of of accepting this is the situation
and now i love it i'm really happy in my
skin
i have made such incredible friends and
i know beautiful people
with dwarfism and maybe i wouldn't know
them if i didn't have dwarfism the
reason why i'm not on that line
is because i surf and i wish my arms
were a little bit longer so i could
paddle into bigger waves
otherwise i'm all good obviously there
are going to be
moments where it's like oh this would be
a lot easier if i was average height
but like it's just fun finding things
about being a little person that like
makes you enjoy it because like average
height people can't really say the same
it's like because
since the world is built for abstract
people like you know everyone can do
a lot of the same things we only live
once and
this is our life and this is what we
were set to do live it the best you can
and like
kevin was saying you know like there's
so many different discoveries you can
find out about yourself
yeah i somewhat agree because
when i was in my late teens i
went down the rabbit hole of trying to
figure out
dwarfism history itself and it's so
hard to find because the community
has been completely like
demolished through the media when i
looked back i i found
that little people were worshiped in
ancient egypt
and that really woke me up and when i
kept continuing down that
i saw that they were given high power
positions and i started realizing this
it was a prevalent thing in other
cultures and
people would come up to me and try to
pat my head or kiss my face
and i it really threw me off at first
and then i started realizing in other
cultures that it was like
a negative thing to not touch a little
person
and i agree with all you guys are saying
but i will be lying to myself and i will
be lying to you guys
if somehow a blue fairy tale just come
fairy tale fairy just come here and give
me the opportunity of just
being normal i would probably
pick it but i understand um exactly all
you guys are saying
and i i identify a lot with all these
experiences
so yeah so i that's that's that's my
only
that's my only thing but hey we're here
and we're making the best out of it and
i'm so proud of all you guys i'm
happy that i met you and yeah that's
just
i'm happy i met me too
and that is officially a wrap you guys
awesome
[Music]
nice
you